okay it is time for hatred mail hatred
mail delayed recently because of the
virus we finally do have our new that's
a story for the bonus show maybe we have
our new hatred mails and we have one
today quick reminder what is Patriot
mail because Mexico is still paying for
the wall right I mean that's what he
said it all the campaign Patriot mail
written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay
this hatred mail has what is now one of
my favorite hatred phrases see if you
can identify it take a listen
David Pakman is a NASA shell David
Pakman is trash David Pakman is still a
shell whom plays identity politics while
defending corp Dems you lie all the time
long propaganda Pakman you're such a
shell and propagandist and low IQ
despite Judaism in YouTube channel ASAP
get real job please get a real job get a
real job has really become one of my
favorites right now because it shows me
the anger that so many people actually
have that this is my job you know we've
got a business now with over a million
viewers across all of our platforms
self-sustaining right like we we did it
we built it from the ground up were
supported by members who say I want to
pay a few bucks a month to support the
work that we do
we're supported by advertisers who say
hey when you recommend a product to your
audience that works
thank you David we employ four people
plus independent contractors lawyer
accountant a web team if that's not real
I don't know what is so get a real job
has very quickly become one of my
favorites also you know I I don't want
to ignore low IQ
despite Judaism is a nice touch it's
sort of like an amalgam of multiple do
current discriminatory and vile ideas
but my message to you is fight hate
reott ism by using the coupon code hey
tree at forty when you get a membership
on my website if you go to join
pakman.com select any membership and
type in hey tree at forty h80
r io t 4-0 you save 40% and the hey tree
'it's don't like it they don't like it
one bit